do you like rocket League are you ready  to shoot some hoops instead of goals I'm  Tony and this game spot news update is a  slam dunk rocket league's new basketball  mode dribbles onto the court on Tuesday  April 26th this completely free update  requires you to knock aerial shots into  the hoop if you want to score in the new  dunk house arena you'll also get a  complimentary NBA logo flag to deck out  your car and if you want to support your  favorite team you can pick up the  two-dollar NBA flag pack which includes  the logos of all 30 NBA teams first  there was hockey and now there's  basketball developer psionics has also  teased a future crossover with euro  truck simulator so there's certainly a  lot going on in the world of rocket  League to keep up with all the latest  you can hang out with team gamespot